[Music]
let's go to dan in
denver dan you have to have a family
question or you can't be on the show
today
i do have a family question
hey well done dan way to go man so
what's up
yeah uh so my my mother and
father-in-law they've been going back
and forth about getting a divorce for
the past couple years that sounds
healthy and early
how long have you been married
uh we've been married just about four
years now oh boy
i'm not laughing at you man i'm just
like oh man oh i know you you married
into a mess huh
i did indeed still love them but yeah
but we we still love them it's like when
my dog craps on the floor it's like ah
well we still love him
all right so you married into a mess
they've been trying to think about
getting divorced for the last four years
so what's up
yeah so then early last year things got
really bad between them my mother-in-law
actually attempted suicide oh my gosh
and
so then later in the same year
father-in-law told the whole family that
he was a sex addict and he was going to
go get treatment to help him out
as far as we know that doesn't include
him sleeping with anybody
but then earlier this year
he was told that he has early onset
dementia or is in the early stages of
dementia
and so things between the two of them
started seemed like they were getting
better but they blew up about a week ago
because it turns out
he hadn't been changing any behaviors
that he said he had been
so now they're a lot closer to divorce
and so we're just trying to figure out
how to set up some healthy boundaries
with her family um and with our family
we have one young daughter we have
another daughter due here in a couple
days and so just trying to figure out
boundaries to put in place with this
whole mess
dude homie you are in it right now man
yep
so can we just pause and talk about that
are you doing okay because this is i'm
smiling not
whenever things hit the fan um
and i enter into a crisis situation i'll
just i'm telling you i smile it's it's
just like a way my i don't know why my
body reacts that way it's more of like
oh man now we're in it dude brother
you're in it
yep have you stopped just to take
inventory of all that's going on
in your particular life yeah okay i have
my wife and i we've yeah we we do really
well together talking through these
things and handling these issues and
obviously i think it's harder on her
being her parents but
yeah it is because
it's hard because that's her parents and
she's watching him go through this and
there's some shame and embarrassment and
frustration and she's been living with
this her whole life
but also
you have a young child
you have a
very very pregnant wife you got another
child on the way
you've got covid you've got
job stuff
and you've got a hurting wife
because her family's a mess and often i
find husbands in the epicenter of those
things
and they start coming unraveled trying
to keep everything held together
yeah it feels that way yeah it feels
chaotic make sure please dan
make sure
you got a couple of buddies you can just
go hang out with okay then you can get
away and just go
man this is hard or this sucks or
let's do something let's root for the
astros or something let's do something
right
um do you have that in your life
i do okay yeah i got you
good friends good family good good good
please double down on that all right
so
you may not know the answer to this
a hallmark of sex addiction is somebody
has lots and lots of sex compulsively
what is
what why does your father-in-law think
he's a sex addict that doesn't have sex
yeah that's so that's part of the
confusion with us the way he's described
it his sex addiction is it's just with
online issues okay a lot of pornography
and a lot of
chat rooms and stuff he's not very clear
about it
yeah it's so i don't know that's the
term he used he wasn't diagnosed that he
gave himself the diagnosis
yeah if that's his like escape from it
or an excuse to say well i'm an addict
and
okay all right that's just what that's
the term he chose to use for us okay
um and then walk me back to
your mother-in-law trying to take her
life what happened there
yeah so that was before he had like come
out and told us that he was a sex addict
but things were getting really bad
between them they were living in the
same house but on separate floors so he
was in the basement and
there was just a big argument one night
and she had taken a bunch of pills and
had texted us that she's sorry she won't
be around to see us oh gosh she like
told us everything that her dad had been
doing and shared all his online profiles
and stuff and
ben just said she loved us and so we
called the police and we were four hours
away from her so we
got in the car right away and drove
there and thankfully she was okay and
she seems to be doing a lot better good
i'm glad you all oh man good for you i'm
glad y'all called 9-1-1 and got involved
that way
um
this feels like and again this is not in
reference to the suicide attempt okay
but this feels like a
super volatile
highly manipulative
feels like a mess actually
um
that really
here's my concern brother i'm afraid
this is gonna really negatively impact
your new marriage
if it hasn't already is it all ready
um honestly i don't think it has my wife
and i we i mean we spend 34 minutes a
night reconnecting and talking and
processing how we're doing and
so yeah we're together the two of us
were actually doing really well with all
of us awesome and she's a lot she's able
to get some distance between the chaos
and
madness that is her family and
understanding that y'all two have a
different relationship moving forward
yep okay all right so here's i mean the
easiest most straightforward way to do
boundaries in your home
especially with two kids and especially
with the situation you find yourself in
is not to create boundaries from people
but to create boundaries for yourself
and so
if you just create boundaries for
they're not allowed to come over anymore
whoever they happens to be
that ends up being really difficult for
somebody when that's their mom or that's
my best friend so i hear you know like
hey that your best friend isn't allowed
in this house anymore because they're
whatever
well that feels like a personal attack
because that's my friend and now you're
saying something about me and let's now
we got other layers to this thing or
your dad's not welcome in this house
anymore he's gross he creeps me out he
always is disgusting he didn't push
stuff back i don't want him in my house
i oh that's cool i get that but that's
my dad you know what i mean so it gets
personal the right way to do boundaries
is
what kind of ethos do we want in this
house who do we want in our home what
kind of energy do we want here who do we
want to be around
and we don't want people who are going
to be dishonest in this house we don't
want people who are going to lie about
us or to us or we don't want chaos in
this house we want people who are fun we
want and so it's a much more it's a it's
an exciting fun
exercise to create the world that you
want to have and then people opt in or
out of that thing does that make sense
yeah i said it now i owe the previous
caller another hundred dollars man i
always say does that make sense i'm
trying to stop it's like a drug
um
so i would create boundaries about what
you do want in your home and my guess is
your in-laws are not going to fit in
that in those categories i don't want
people around my kids who are going to
be dishonest who are going to who
self-proclaim they have
sex addictions and they don't get help
for them and i don't want you around my
daughters
um i don't want people in my home that
are going to make my wife cry
or that are going to make me
uncomfortable in my own house whatever
that looks like and then you backfill
who are the people in my life that we're
gonna we're going to have to have hard
conversations with
um
are they gonna
have it get a divorce
uh
it's hard to say okay i really don't
know he's gone he's gone to a divorce
attorney multiple times and
he says he has papers ready to go he's
just not using them yet okay sorry so
that's a that is a cornerstone
nonsense
triangulation threat bullcrap and that
was my biggest i just tried to do a
bunch of things so i wouldn't say bad
words
so
i need you to tell him next time he does
that i don't care
i don't care
i don't care if you stay married i don't
care if you get divorced i don't want to
hear about that
or
that's a callous way to say that a more
respectful dignified way is
hey i really am uncomfortable hearing
about whether you're gonna divorce my
mother-in-law or not i'll let y'all that
please keep that private between y'all
too
and same with your wife if she'll have
that conversation hey dad i i don't want
to hear about you threatening to divorce
my mom that's a private marriage matter
between you all too please keep that um
in your personal thing
in your in your personal world
and i'm gonna begin to draw bound i'm
not going to get sucked into other
people's dramas not your job and not
your wife's job and i'm getting all
fired up not at you at that kind of
manipulative nonsense it's not your job
to keep their marriage together
and it's not your job to
be a punching bag for that kind of
nonsense
there he's trying to
hit his wife by hitting you
you know what i mean
yeah he's trying to get a rise out of
her by getting a rise out of you
nonsense nonsense yeah dude i cut that
crap off man
your your marriage is too special to get
dragged down by that nonsense ugh i
can't stand that
he's torturing that poor woman and his
mother-in-law and
yeah i'm not getting involved in that
stuff so sit down with your wife decide
we have two kids we have we have our own
household what kind of world do we want
and then right
the ethical right way the the integris
way to do it is to sit down with your
father-in-law sit down your
mother-in-law and say here's the kind of
here's what the kind of people we're
going to
allow into our lives and here's the kind
of people we're not
every time you come to my house you talk
about this and this and this and this
i'm gonna ask you to not bring up your
marriage dysfunction in my home anymore
you need to find your own counselor your
own therapist your own friends that's
not our job
and that will be a hard conversation
if they were able to have that
conversation maturely with you or your
wife then that'd be one thing they are
immature they can't do it
and your mother your mother-in-law needs
to get some mental health support in a
major way but you can't make her do that
and
if she tells you yeah i'm going to take
my life again of course it's your
responsibility to call on that but it's
her responsibility to take care of
herself does that make sense ah i said
it again yeah
i said it again
it works i know what you mean so what is
the what's your takeaway here man
uh yeah so we we had been talking about
some boundaries and how to set them up
and the biggest thing was trying to
figure out how we convey that to them
and i think we were going more with the
restrictive you know you're just not
allowed here
but i like what you said about you know
what kind of home do we want to have and
then
going at it from that different
perspective and having those hard
conversations because my wife's big
concern is you know maintaining those
relationships especially with you know
going to be having two daughters and she
wants them to have a relationship with
her dad with her mom that's right she's
trying to figure out how to do that
here's where this is really important
okay really important and it goes back
to the conversation i'm just having i
just read this email from from uh from a
caller
no matter how bad our parents treat us
we all have a fantasy that when we have
our kids here's what life with grandkids
is going to look like
and so the impetus is almost always felt
by the new young parents
to concede to grandparents
we've got to go visit them
they
are mad that they don't get to see their
grandkids enough so we've got to go do
this we've got to buy these things their
grandkids are going to wear these kind
of clothes so we got to spend their
grandkids need to ride around in this
kind of car so we got to buy a car that
we can't even afford on payments because
we can't
it's almost always the young family that
feels the need to reach across that
aisle and that's nonsense
so
your dad
is choosing to be dysfunctional
he is making decisions to not get well
to not go to counseling to not deal with
his challenges
he is choosing to threaten
the status of his marriage with his kids
and so it's him that is choosing to not
see his granddaughters not the other way
around
and never lose sight of that okay
because you will feel so guilty
and that guilt will turn into resentment
especially with somebody who's as
immature as your father-in-law
and it's not y'all's responsibility to
deal with his or your mother-in-law's
dysfunction
it's your responsibility to protect your
children
and to create a loving rambunctious
fun laughter joy-filled home as much as
you can control
and you can control whether a
an addict who is choosing to lie to his
family
is in
contact with your daughters
and he can choose to either be in
contact or not be in contact
does that make sense
for the third freaking time
yeah um
really watch out for the fantasy of
our time together as a small new family
and that will be something if you have
to kill that fantasy that your
father-in-law just chooses to
not be a part of your family that your
mother-in-law chooses to not be a part
of this new young beautiful family
you all have to mourn that and grieve it
it stinks man it's not supposed to be
that way they're all supposed to hang
out together they're supposed to
man come and bring joy and too much
candy and you're supposed to be like
they don't need that much candy and
they're supposed to be like candy
they're supposed to sneak away and get
done they're supposed to do those things
your grandparents
and if they opt out of y'all's
boundaries
that's heartbreaking
and you can choose sadness because it's
sad
but don't choose to compromise your
family's values don't choose to
compromise the integrity of your young
family who and what you want your family
to be who you want around your daughters
to try to
try to duct tape together a myth
a fantasy a picture you have about what
family's supposed to look like
because y'all are not dealing with
mature grown-ups you're dealing people
who are hurting you're dealing with
people who are choosing to not lean into
wellness they're choosing to lean into
their dysfunction it's heartbreaking man
i hate that for you guys stand strong
create the world you want to and then
have those hard conversations and by the
way dan it may be that you say
you're not welcome here but it's going
to be an outflow of what we want us to
be not i'm just going to prohibit you
from being here and i hope you get that
difference
man your kids are lucky to have two
parents like you and your wife that are
looking out for
the the culture and the energy in that
home good for you good for you good for
you